it's ridiculous how
how much money they have to be able to
they spend millions and millions and
millions
of dollars how many 18 wheelers he's got
so shows he's got about
15 18 wheelers to 2018 wheelers outside
with all the props and all the stuff two
of them and the broadcasting units
where they're editing and sending it to
the live
you know the live there's two there's
two trucks doing that [ __ ]
but um the rest is uh i wonder if
there's a documentary
on like what it takes to run behind the
scenes
all the trucks the [ __ ] the crap
yeah and the riggers to rigging
beforehand
it's you know to rig everything up it's
literally it's literally like a
major motion picture budget for a one
one time live show
yeah so so you know and that's what he's
doing she
what he does too you know like he did
the uh bradley center
in um
there's this in brooklyn what's it
called
the barclays center barclay berkeley
center
friday night was nxt you know that's
okay
now that's on wednesday night right now
on on usa network
nxt that's the the other the guys coming
up right
nxt he did on friday night in the
barclay
he did saturday night he he did um
the hall of fame in the barclay center
sunday they did the outdoor and
meadowlands
the wrestlemania i'm talking about in
the new york
last year before then he come back on
monday night at the barclays center
tuesday night the barclay center monday
night was raw
tuesday night with smackdown so here's
the barclays center
so you just one set up oh yeah yeah
that's what they did in new orleans as
well yeah see that's what they said
yes and it's coming to tampa this year
yeah but it's going to be there that's
going to be insane
emilia arena for the the emily arena
emily arena for wrestlemania no no
no emily arena no it's a buck stadium
wrestling oh these are
james james okay and that
is for the um nxt the hall of fame
and then monday and tuesday raw and
smackdown
okay yeah unreal that'll be a long week
yeah that's gonna be wild yep and then
are you gonna be there yeah yeah
and then um not for them no
there and then there's you know when
where there's wrestlemania
there's usually about eight wrestling
shows around it
all the big independent companies in the
states
go to you know new orleans there was
stuff going
from thursday oh yeah even though they
had wwe had their stuff
russell khan and all that yeah all that
there's rest of crime there's
there's a roh there's a
there's all these different other
companies running you know
this year roh will be running and they
run
they run lakeland that's the closest
they can get their building
and that all the other places have been
bought
by different companies you know what i
mean it's going to be insane
that's what the guy the mayor in orlando
that's why he
he gives him everything for nothing the
wwe because it brings so much tourists
from overseas to his place because when
they come to
the rest of you know wrestlemania draws
from japan
from all europe and that from new
zealand australia brings drawers from
all over the world right
and that's so when so you know orlando
they've got
sea world they've got everything there
so that's why he gives it because
the tourists not only come for
wrestlemania they catch everything
now tamper two will they'll get they'll
get them because people will come here
to go to to orlando to catch everything
else too
okay yeah boost the whole city during
yeah
that rails they should i don't know when
they're going to get that rail going but
they're going to have that rail running
to a from orlando to fort lauderdale
it's a tampa yeah you know that one a
speed train or whatever it is or
something i don't like the bullet
that's in the makings i don't know when
that's going to happen that'll be
[ __ ] nice
yeah by the time you drive to the place
and
then get sit around get on the plane and
then get off and that is
if they get the the plane like the
bullet 120 130 mile an hour
150 mile an hour train cruising it's
easier to do you know
yeah i was going to ask you guys what
kind of [ __ ] like
injuries have you had have you had some
pretty terrible injuries have you had to
have like
surgeries and back because i know hulk's
pretty messed up from all back surgeries
i've held all from back surgery but i've
had two
right knee replacements the first
replacement i wore
out wrestling and that and um i did 40
years lasted 14 years
in the ring oh yeah and that and the new
one has got spike
you know where it goes into the the bone
and goes up in the other one
it was round before so it's just like
that where it goes up
and it was smooth now there's a little
there's little spikes on it so when they
cement it in
with the spikes it can't get loose okay
yeah
the last one i had a tour in england and
it was loose and it was
it was like electric shocks in my leg
i was i was loaded on um
painkillers painkillers yeah yeah i had
to do it too
somebody some xanax or something ah were
you taking xanax or
no that's not a painkiller
valium valium knows like i said
the same thing the good stuff that's
what the
valley i'm sorry i'm sorry the xanax is
what you feed the sheep first yeah
that is that anyhow um yeah so
it said my career that's where i came in
like then i came to the states i lived
in hawaii
you know i worked across across canada
you know right across canada in the 70s
and um and a wee bit in the states but i
was living in canada
and then in 79 79 i came 78
79 that came and i was living in hawaii
and we used to
work on four islands a week and then and
i used to fly over
diamond head every night and see jack
lord and the crew
doing hawaii five-o
come right low in that and i could look
right down and see him
doing hawaii 5-0 that's cool yeah that
was um
that was great but i mean in hawaii
i i just kept my head above water yeah i
didn't make any money you know what i
mean right
i made money to survive i lived right
across so i lived on
waikiki beach and that
got up every morning went to the gym by
10 o'clock i was on the beach every day
at 5 30 i would fly out to one of the
islands
we had our the probably had his own
planes we'd fly to the islands
and do an island i'd be back back in
waikiki around um 10 o'clock every night
that's where the rock's from right he's
from hawaii isn't he yeah the rock
yeah he used to live in hawaii when he
was yeah because because
um his grand his grandma
and grandfather peter mavia
they owned the promotion down the road
they
owned the promotion and you know he was
born
in the states he lived in new zealand
too for two years did he really yeah
i wrestled the i wrestled the rock's
grandfather
me and butch wrestled them are you
serious
you know in hall of fame we told the
story about that we
we wrestled um peter marvier the rock's
grandfather
and then the rock's dad i've wrestled i
i still see him a lot and that i
wrestled him
in australia new zealand in the states
no way
the rock's dead everywhere but but the
rock's grandfather
i wrestled just in australia and and new
zealand were they anything like the rock
what were those guys like
yeah it's not the rock's third
generation right where do you think you
got it from exactly
yeah i said it's before my time so
that's why i got to ask no the rock's
grandfather
peter marvel was a high chief
chief in that and he was in the first
james bond movies
he was a lot of movies bit parts oh [ __ ]
no way he's the one that had to fight
and went through the screen and in the
movie with kindle sticks
at the start of that first was that
doctor
doctor no what was the first first james
i can't remember
that's going way back yeah but um that
he was a
he was in those movies and that and then
then
rocky johnson he was a big name he was
the first
him him
him and tony atlas were the first black
people ever to have the wwe f
12 belts you know they were the first
black
people to have the world well straps and
in wrestling town
yeah rocky johnson i work with him all
over the
all over the states yeah and in
australia and in new zealand
that's wild yeah i mean i actually i
actually met his uh his mom
at uh ric flair's wedding yeah i went
there and i made a little video i made
like a little documentary about his
wedding and his mom was there
and i got to talk to her i did a little
interview
brock's mom and dad they're like super
involved in in wrestling yeah they're
super cute
they're super close to so many different
people like like ric flair well they're
broken up now but um they've still live
in the same street
and that's who's broken up the rock's
mum and dad oh oh
yeah they live in the same street as the
rock down to davey but uh
because rock pulled all the homes for
the family there where where is that at
dan davey where's davey south florida
lake lauderdale
oh okay yeah anyhow
um mum and dad used to come to our
restaurant
when they had the bushwhackers down at a
steakhouse
on down mayberry and that they used to
come here all the time
[Music]
[Laughter]
i